Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
Marvel just dropped the first look
at Deadpool and Wolverine
in the Deadpool three movie with Wolverine
in his full on yellow costume,
showing you like a full HD look at it.
their tagline was now in Hue Res.
So we'll break it all down.
Just because this is getting so
comic book,
you cannot wait
to see the rest of the movie.
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
be releasing a lot more first
looks like this
just because
they're filming a lot outside.
So things are going to get real crazy
in the best possible way.
Right.
Okay, guys, this you too. Good.
And he's literally all.
really feels like
this movie is going to be much closer
to what people expected from Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of Madness.
but as you can see, this yellow
suit is based on the one from astonishing
X-Men or closer to astonishing X-Men
than any of the other eras.
the one you saw
during the Wolverine movie.
Like that scene of him
getting the yellow costume
that he never actually put on
was more yellow and brown.
And it was based on a lot
of the comic book costumes,
but not any official comic book costume.
My guess is that he
probably won't be wearing the helmet
all the time in the movie
just so his face is fully visible
all the time, with the exception
of some of the big fight scenes,
like when Deadpool sees him
for the first time,
like you don't see
where his helmet is in this,
like it's not attached to his back
or anything like that.
it is not totally clear which universe
they're in during this particular scene
but they're outside of sitting
in the wasteland of some kind.
The theory is right now
they're paying off the A38 Universe story
in the ending of Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness,
with the surviving Illuminati characters
wanting revenge against Scarlet Witch
and what happened
during that movie. R.I.P.
to most of that team.
So it's possible that a lot of the X-Men
that are coming back in
the movie are the more comic book versions
from that universe.
like we saw a version of Professor X
in that movie based on X-Men,
the Animated series.
They even played the theme song
when he showed up.
he used the yellow floaty chair.
His suit and tie look similar
to X-Men, the animated series.
So it makes sense if they're going
to visit that universe again.
And we see some of the other X-Men
coming back, baby wearing more colorful
comic book based uniforms, too.
In that universe.
but the entire movie
might not take place in the 838 universe
just because Deadpool is hopping around
with cable's time travel device,
which they also confirm that cable
is not coming back for them to be.
Josh Brolin's cable
will not be in the movie, but his time
travel device will be a big part
of how the movie plays out.
but because Patrick Stewart is coming back
again as another version of Professor
X, either
he's in a completely different universe
when Deadpool is hopping around
or the universe that he goes to and pulls
this Wolverine from
is not the A38 universe.
But for instance, Cyclops is coming back
from those movies.
James Marsden
And he'll be wearing a version of his suit
based on X-Men, the Animated series.
Again, the blue one,
but without the yellow trunks,
just still very close to X-Men.
The Animated series same thing
with all the other X-Men characters
that you heard coming back.
Most of them are coming back
like Halle Berry.
Storm will be close to her
comic book uniform.
Jean Gray Ian McKellen Magneto's suit
will be closer to his comic book suit.
in based on comments that Elizabeth Olsen
made this past weekend
at a convention appearance.
It sounds like she's also coming
back, too.
I knew the movie would reference her
in some way.
Wasn't sure
if she was actually coming back,
but now it actually seems more possible
Oh, gosh.
I just want to figure out
the whole mutant thing.
Like, that's really and I don't like,
none of us can do anything
about it, you know, like,
we can't do anything about it.
We're not born, we're not X-Men.
But, gosh, like, I just.
I just would love to explore that so much.
I think X-Men was definitely
my first experience
with superhero type films.
she said the next big thing
that she wanted to do in the Marvel
movies was explain whether or not she was
really a mutant like the other X-Men
in her history with Magneto.
Like, is she really Magneto's daughter?
So what she meant during
that is she wants to address her
character's connection in crossover
with the X-Men comics
just because Scarlet Witch
crossed over a lot
with the X-Men comics in the past
and it sounds like they're using
the house of M part of that story,
or whichever universe that winds up being.
I don't know
if it's going to be the A38 universe
or a completely separate universe,
but I believe it's
the one where this Wolverine
is meant to come from.
end, in that universe, they'll canonize
that version of Scarlet Witch,
that alternate reality, Scarlet Witch,
as Ian McKellen magneto's daughter.
But in that reality we seen Scarlet
Witch is Father inside the MCU.
But I think the idea is that it's
meant to be her adoptive father.
So that's the whole idea in the comics,
even though there's been
a couple continuity changes
the funny thing is recently
we just had the high evolutionary
in Guardians of the Galaxy three.
Scarlet Witch's backstory actually crosses
over with high evolutionary
in a really interesting way, like way,
way back in the comics originally.
Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver
were born to Magda in Magneto.
But the local townspeople found out
that it was Magneto and came to kill him.
So Magda fled with the twins
she went to Matt one day Gore,
which we saw in the Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness movie
where the high evolutionary base was
and gave birth to the twins.
There during the Guardians of the Galaxy
three movie, we saw the human animal
like the creations
of the high evolutionary, the half human
half animal hybrids in the comics
Bova was one of his first creations.
Bova helped Magda in the twins.
And then once they were born, high
evolutionary was basically like,
Get out of here, you can't stay.
so Bova took baby, Quicksilver and Scarlet
Witch and gave them to the Maximoff
And that's why they
have the Maximoff name, not the lynch name
for Magneto's last name,
they were raised by the Maximus,
they were their adoptive parents and did
learn about their back story with Magneto
being their father till much, much later.
They almost got into that
during the mainline X-Men movies before
Disney bought out Fox,
like when they introduced
Quicksilver's character
and he meets Magneto for the first time,
like, Oh, you seem kind of like a guy
that my mother used to know.
during that movie, he had two sisters,
he had Polaris and Wanda
but the reason why they didn't go fully
there was is because of the weird
rights issue and they had already used
Scarlet Witch in Avengers Age of Ultron.
So it got a little bit crazy
with the rights
now it sounds like
because Marvel got the characters back,
they can actually fully address that now
and pay it off in Deadpool
three in some way,
but it'll be Ian McKellen's magneto.
They do it with just because the age
difference is a little more correct
Elizabeth Olsen also said that
if they did do a version of her storyline
with Magneto being her father,
she would prefer that it be with Ian
McKellen as Magneto,
not Michael Fassbender.
Oh, I'm going to go with Sir Ian McKellen.
the thing about that is though,
is that Ian McKellen's magneto
is just meant to be the future
version of Michael Fassbender as Magneto.
So technically that does make Michael
Fassbender's Magneto, her father
just a younger version of him.
but as far as I know,
he's not supposed to be in Deadpool three.
Like the only version of Magneto
will be Ian McKellen as Magneto,
or an alternate reality version of him.
But. In Deadpool three, the rumor
is that in the alternate universe.
Professor X in the X-Men
originally wound up siding
with Magneto in the Brotherhood of Mutants
instead of fighting against them.
during the events of the first X-Men
movie, remember, during the events of that
movie, Magneto was trying to forcibly
mutate a giant portion of the world.
So the majority of the population
would be mutants, and they would reign
supreme over regular humans.
during the movie, Deadpool
supposedly winds up trying to win
over that universe's version of Wolverine,
it ultimately it's that universe
that Deadpool winds up
causing the destruction of it.
Kevin Feige He also said that in addition
to that, just like within the scope
of Marvel Phase six, Deadpool
three would be a big tipping point.
With the incursion
storyline leading up to Avengers
five, Qing Dynasty and Secret Wars.
a bunch of universes being destroyed.
And it sounds like Deadpool
does something so crazy that it winds up
causing a bunch of incursions
in tons of universes get destroyed.
Not just that one.
And that'll pay off.
The Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe.
Part of the storyline
that they're also adapting
so it's kind of like they're combining
the Loki storyline with the TVA
with a version of House of them
and Deadpool kills the Marvel Universe,
one of the other big casting announcements
you probably heard about a little while
ago isn't an X-Men character,
but they just announced Matthew McFayden,
who plays Tom on succession,
will be playing a TVA agent assigned
by Mobius to follow Deadpool
and try unsuccessfully.
But he'll try to keep Deadpool
from messing up other timelines.
sounds like he's going to fail
pretty hard.
They just had the succession finale too,
so this is kind of timely
that we talk about his character,
I believe his role is going to be
sort of deadpool's comedic
punching bag, like a similar type of role
that he plays on succession,
a hapless idiot
who thinks way too highly of himself
that Deadpool just walks all over
Mobius said.
You're not allowed to mess with this
timeline. Don't cause any Nexus events.
And immediately
Deadpool just completely balks.
The entire universe.
cannot wait
to see what all the other X-Men actually
do look like full on in their costumes.
So just post all your reactions.
I'm so happy that they're finally
giving us Wolverine in a comic book.
Accurate yellow costume.
To be honest, though,
one of the reasons why
they probably dropped this
this week in particular
not only because they're filming outdoors
with Hugh Jackman's Wolverine.
So people were going to see low
res potato quality versions of it anyway.
but there's a probably released it
because Warner Brothers
is releasing the Barbie movie.
It looks like that's actually going
to do gangbusters.
Unlike the Flash movie, usually Disney
and Marvel will do stuff like that
when other studios
release their big movies like, Oh,
here's a big teaser for thing that people
have been waiting for for a long time.
They also just released
a brand new Ahsoka teaser trailer,
so I'll do a video for that next.
That should be up
either later tonight or Tuesday.
be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
I'll do more Deadpool three videos.
When we get more footage from the set
or we learn more about what's going on
with the cameos.
The other X-Men, the Fantastic
Four characters that are coming back,
or other Fox Marvel people in general,
like Ben Affleck's Daredevil click.
Here for all my Deadpool
3 videos to learn about all the other
big cameos and click here
for all my secret Invasion videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!